but don't worry it's not just major
corporations that are guilty of greed
here in the united states congress has a
very serious problem
with using their insider knowledge
to buy and sell stocks
we have seen the reports you know a
business insider earlier this year maybe
even early last year whatever it was 64
members of congress in the last two
years have violated the stock act
almost 200 of their staffers have also
violated the stock act
and of course these individuals have
information
they've got budget information they know
where money's going to be spent before
it gets spent
and they can use this information
to buy stocks they can use it to sell
stocks
and a majority of americans 70 percent
of them to be exact
say they want a ban on congressional
stock trading
50 percent of republicans and 45 percent
of democrats say they're actually going
to be more likely to vote for a
candidate if they support a ban on
politicians trading stocks
i personally
you may think it's a little extreme
i want to go further than just banning
them buying and selling stocks
i don't think they should be allowed to
own them sorry
again that's just me you can disagree
that's fine doesn't matter doesn't
bother me
but you're choosing a life of public
service
you've got to give those things up they
made jimmy carter sell his peanut farm
now if he had to sell his peanut farm i
don't think it's too far-fetched to say
that members of congress should have to
sell their raytheon stock
not a blind trust i want it banned they
can't own it at all
but i would also settle if this is the
best case scenario with a ban on them
buying and selling it
and so would of course 70 percent of the
american public and the biggest problem
is this stock act that all these
congress people keep violating democrats
and republicans alike it's a bipartisan
issue
you know what the penalty is for
violating it
200 fine
if the fine is even
you know put in place sometimes they
waive the fine
so you could trade 50 000 worth of stock
you could buy 50 000 you know profit 10
20 30
whatever it is
you can make ten twenty thirty thousand
dollars off of it
and the only penalty you have is a two
hundred dollar fine
for violating the stock act at that
point that's not a fine that's just a
fee for doing business
listen that's all the time we have for
today's show we've got some great stuff
coming up in today's bonus show
including a republican who has been
removed from office for killing a man
i'm farren cousins find me at
youtube.com the ring of fire youtube.com
fair and balanced
thank you for watching and of course
stay tuned for the bonus show
our sponsor javi makes coffee from
concentrate this is so fast and easy and
convenient and i'm looking for fast easy
and convenient right now but i don't
want to sacrifice on flavor the taste is
great it's cost effective you can use it
for hot or cold coffee it comes in
original decaf caramel or caramel please
pick whichever pronunciation you want
french vanilla and mocha it does not
have sugar it does not have dairy you
can add whatever liquid you want water
milk oat milk etc the ingredients are
delicious coffee concentrate and for the
flavored ones natural flavors the coffee
is ethically sourced click the link in
the description
use code pacman for 25
off